[Music]
assalamualaikum what happened too late
better care simple system is the offense
today's video something special as you
guys know well firstly me I was thinking
okay what can I eat and what can I not
be in Ramadan there and I thought what's
the best thing to do you know let's just
search online then I thought you know
what this is what I know after all
Instagram
it is a lobby there is a nutritionist
from my mistakes and nutrition yeah
herbal nutrition is something I lacked
so I thought you know what let's do a
video them do you I'm trying to say and
he can tell us that the things that we
can paint and not it and a fluid
beneficial for you guys as well cuz
Ramadan side for five days away yeah so
I thought the best thing to do for all
of us is to know what we can eat that
computers hydrated and full of energy
through out no matter what we're doing
and this means that we should have seen
from so yeah
however one rule is I'm going to connect
straight to Toronto yes or going to
Canada
yes so what we're going to do is we're
going to connect to the brother and he's
going to get papers free the foods that
we should eat and not eating Ramadan 10
things to eat and tasting stuff same
from so let's let's get internet Allah
Salam aleikum a key can you hear me
hello well I'm a fulness and I see how
are you doing Marcia lucky now bless you
how's the weather house within Canada is
one Allah has really definitely colder
come little now the weather in Canada is
great Springs coming and there are no
doors on the way so that's very exciting
mashallah mashallah that's good so
alright the first question we need to
ask if you want to know who's this guy
you can it can do is it just some guy
that you just found whatever yeah so
what was your background ask what your
you said you're the turbo nutritionist
so today about yourself in the field
that you're in so I've been a horrible
practitioner for about five years and
I've been in the health food business
for about ten years
so insha'Allah the advice I'm going to
be providing you guys is the best advice
to help you stay full and to avoid
getting hungry
okay but upon defeat may Allah bless you
for that insha'Allah okay this best part
way straight Oh in karate the ten foods
to eat to abstain from and tenses we
should eat or vice versa
I leave it in des Coachella I'll go over
the top 10 foods that people should
avoid to stop them from getting hungry
number one is sugary pop which is full
of sugar and full of caffeine and also
will stop you from being hydrated
throughout the day
number two is store-bought juice which
is pasteurized so they actually
eliminate all the good nutrients at
enzyme and it's full of sugar as well
and will keep you dehydrated for sure
people should make their own juice at
home that would be the best to do 3 is
packaged cereal which is full of
genetically modified food destroys your
gut health and also full of flavorings
as well and this these types of things
will make you stay hungry throughout the
day the next day non-organic candy is
full of high fructose corn syrup and it
keeps you dehydrated processed chips
most salty foods are using just a
regular salt which is a highly processed
and it does keep you in hydrated and it
also makes you very hungry you should
try to go with a Himalayan pink salt or
sea salt and those are the best to cook
with the next I'll talk about this
process dairy most dairy nowadays is
either factory farmed or is a
pasteurized and they do have a lot of
toxins inside them that stop you from
feeling full and they do keep you
feeling like you're hungry as well so
fat free foods your body does need fat
but it needs good fat so things from
like avocados but when you have fat free
foods your body is being deprived from a
nutrient that it needs but it just needs
a good version of it most of the
processed foods have trans fats which is
very bad for your body but in general
our but we do need good fats and our
body does benefit
some good facts and it does help us
distasteful and help our bodies a
functional optimal level as well refined
grains as well so most of these refined
grains are genetically modified and they
do have toxins that induce our bodies to
make it more hungry as well so we should
avoid artificial sweeteners because they
have been shown to make you more hungry
and to make you gain more weight not
something that you want during Ramadan
so the last thing that we should avoid
is back food which contains all the
above genetically modified food refined
grains refined sugar these are all
ingredients that make us sick and keep
us hungry and it does not make us feel
full at all ok butterflyfish a female I
bless you for that for 10 feet kind of
things that we should abstain from yes
it's about sisters try your best to
abstain from such foods how about the 10
foods that we should eat that will help
us get through Ramadan and keep it
hydrated and full of energy shall Walia
pee now we'll talk about the top 10
foods that people should have during
Ramadan that will help them stay full
and satisfied number one is date this is
high in antioxidants they will help you
stay energized they're also a lower
glycemic food so won't negatively affect
your blood sugar chia seeds is another
one chia seeds is high in omega threes
it's also high in fiber and it's protein
so I was added to my smoothie drinks the
whole time that would be one of the best
things to do if you don't make a
smoothie you can add it to a salad or
you can even add the sandwiches during
the whole time but chia seeds is
definitely one of those news of one of
those foods that I was including Ramadan
the next one is lentils lentils for
dinner lentil soup but lentils are high
in fiber and they do help you stay full
and satisfied
homeless one of the most
delicious foods considering a million in
total but how most is very high in fiber
and it's very high in protein and I
would include more homeless than my
meals during a lot on for sure
broccoli is very high in fiber it will
also help with cleansing during Ramadan
oats are very high in fiber oats also
has nutrients that helps you stay
energized throughout the day when
they're eating in the night before the
next one we'll talk about is almonds
which is very high in fiber and protein
and helps you stay full and satisfies
the next date it's also very good and
healthy snack so telling your message is
very high in fiber Tiger nuts is also
very well known in Asia for being a type
of food that helps you stay satisfied
for long periods of time and these are
things that you can find at your local
health food store as well
avocados one of my favorite foods is
very high fat this type of fat and very
high in fiber it's amazing for your body
I would have at least one avocado per
day and that's perfect so a start time
the best thing to do is to have a date
make your Salah and then have don't have
too heavy of a meal eat until you're
satisfied then stop and that is the best
way to conduct your Amazon diet why the
most important thing is that we
shouldn't overeat which we shouldn't
gain weight during Ramadan we should
feel like we are eating the most minimal
that we can in order for us to have the
most spiritual and effective Ramadan one
of the most important things to have is
well during Ramadan is coconut oil
coconut oil will help you stay full
satisfied but one of the most important
properties in coconut oil
also keeps you energized throughout the
day so if you have it at the whole time
it's actually perfect to keep your
energy up during the Ramadan during the
daytime and the last one I'll talk about
is barley which is the highest and fiber
out of all the grains and it is a great
ton of food the prophets of long ago
said let me to have barley as well with
his meals so these are the top 10 foods
for keeping you full and satisfied and
healthy during Ramadan so a start time
the best thing to do is to have a date
maybe earth Allah and then have don't
have too heavy of a meal eat until
you're satisfied then stock and that is
the best way to conduct your Amazon
diet-wise the most important thing is
that we should overeat which we should
gain weight during Ramadan we should
feel like we are eating the most minimal
that we can in order for us to have the
most spiritual and effective Ramadan
qualification may Allah bless you
enchilada was amazing I'm gonna add my
little food tips is Waldens Allah may
Allah bless you in sha Allah I'm also a
key here I welcome that problem sisters
following so if you can just quickly
tell us where they can find you a lot to
keep up to date with your nutritional
facts and hurt I just want to say thank
you very much for having me brother and
in sha Allah
you'll have a great Ramadan and you guys
can all follow me on instagram at
holistic Ali
we're also on YouTube at holistic Ali as
well inshallah on putting out health
tips and some great dollar information
as well article of exact Tamela bless
you and Shalom see you very soon shall
one day we can meet in some lexicon
phenomenal if I come there
so guys you fight for yourself now me
person just quickly three times before
you guys go is that recently I just
found out about coconut milk a I know
Tesco's and these other places sell it
but personally I go to Sainsbury's and
it says with this one called Vita Coco
something other it
and it's amazing it's like is
substituted for the very room that you
have the cosmic Accenture with god knows
what happens to it before it comes to
you I know it's really unhealthy as well
coconut milk it tastes better than that
cow's milk here so if you guys want in
Sainsbury's coconut milk do go and get
that as well also one other thing
bothers and sisters instead of it
injunction that Chris chocolate biscuits
sweet etc with sometimes I'm guilty of
as well try to change that to like not
yeah all kinds of nuts and also dried
fruits you know dried apples dried
bananas etc this is what happens kind of
changed it around and also apple cider
vinegar vinegar not vinegar vinegar
apple cider vinegar is really good and
there's something that you can have
after breakfast and before lunch all
these wises I get I get a glass half a
glass of water half a glass of fresh
juice squeezed for the machine and two
tablespoons of apple cider vinegar mix
it and I have that and it really really
helps burn fat and also is good a soft
in the digester you know the digestive
system inshallah so that's about it guys
hope you guys are benefited holy Ramadan
go successful and good and for all of
you brothers and sisters out there use
this expression I'm glad you're going to
be you know trying all your new to
whether it may be a boring sisters don't
fall for the shaitaan strap make sure
you come and inshallah try your best
inside this Ramadan to make a u-turn so
till then a slaw male for what I want to
worry about a kettle
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey give
me one I'm sorry
subscribe whoa